tomorrow morning at sunrise I am to hang
for the murder of a man at sunrise on
the 9th of June the anniversary of my
wedding day I'm to be hanged by the neck
until I am dead I'm glad this state has
not yet adopted the use of electricity
in executions I prefer to spend my last
moments out in the open under the sky
the building of the gallows is finished
the workmen are gone and it seems that
the execution at sunrise is certain to
take place but every step along the
corridor sends my heart into my mouth
GLaDOS is working for a reprieve I am
praying she will not succeed
the governor is off on a fishing trip
away from railroad and telegraph if they
do not locate him in the next few hours
I shall be hanged
god grant they fail to find him it is
Gladys's will against mine she usually
wins but every passing minute lessens
her chance to have her way in this it is
now 10 minutes to midnight doctor
Brander the prison chaplain has just
left me gratified poor fellow that he
has succeeded in reconciling me to my
fate if he had known that the tall
skeleton of wood outside with its lank
line of rope was in my mind a refuge he
would have turned from me and horror the
next five hours will be the longest of
my life every step in the corridor
strikes fear to my heart it is not
because I'm guilty of the crime for
which I was sentenced that I am glad to
die I am guilty but that doesn't mean
that I deserve to die I'm going to hang
tomorrow at sunrise because I want to be
hung I could have saved myself but
refused to do so
solely because life had lost its savor a
great wave of disgust with living
possessed and still possesses me I'm
writing these words now that GLaDOS may
know the truth she has tried to see me
ever since I was brought here and I have
refused to be seen that is one write a
condemned man has to refuse to see
visitors
from the day we were married Gladys
demanded to know my every thought my
every act every hour of the day if every
one of them was not concerned with her
she criticized condemned or cried she
resented in bitterly spoken words and
equally bitter acts the small recesses
of my soul that I for the sake of my own
self-respect kept to myself finally she
determined to show me that there were
other men who appreciated her if I did
not for a while after that all hours of
the day and evening my home was infested
with Lounge Lizards
I endured it without a word which
infuriated her lester cain a young
fellow honest and simple was her first
victim the first time I found him seated
close beside her on the dimly lit porch
I welcomed him warmly we smoked and
talked of our days in the Army together
I felt that Gladys could safely enough
flirt with such as Lester if that was
what she wanted but Lester called only a
few times after that for two months
there was a succession of young fellows
about the place our house was not far
from the Westmore Country Club and the
Golf Links came almost up to our side
yard our porch was a convenient place to
drop in suddenly all of that sort of
things ceased Gladys was away a great
deal but as her mother lived in a town
just a few miles away I thought nothing
of that she became very quiet was
thoughtful absent-minded flushed easily
seemed not herself at first I was a good
deal puzzled then suddenly an
explanation for the change in her dawned
on me joy filled my soul I was
inordinately gentle with her
bought her a small automobile for her
birthday did everything I could think of
for her comfort and pleasure after all I
told myself the emotional phase she had
passed through was natural marriage is a
more difficult readjustment with some
than others it had evidently been so
with Gladys if a child came to us it
would make everything right a child our
child it was wonderful to think of she
had always refused to consider the
subject saying she wished to enjoy life
while she was young but she knew I
wanted a son to bear my name a daughter
to inherit her beauty and
she had accepted the inevitable a wave
of exaltation made me feel as if I were
treading on clouds I longed to mention
the subject to her but I felt that the
first word about it should come from her
I spent hours thinking of tender loving
things to do for her she accepted
everything quietly sometimes with
averted face and flushed cheeks I would
draw her inert figure into my arms and
hold her close but she made no response
to my demonstrative affection at this
stage of affairs my firm sent me on a
ten-day trip to close a Western deal it
was hard to leave Gladys but now more
than ever I felt that we would need
money and lots of it we arranged for
Gladys to go to her mother's and I was
to join her there on my return it's the
same old story I came home before I was
expected and went straight to our
cottage with the intention of having
Gladys's room redecorated before
bringing her home at the gate stood
Gladys his car I rushed into the house
but there was no one on the lower floor
nor in Gladys's room nor mine I was
about to descend the stairs when I heard
a low laugh a man's laugh from the third
floor I dashed up there and stood gazing
at the closed door of the spare room
what's the idea running away from me
asked the man you can't blow hot and
cold with me I told you not to come here
again
it's not safe I'm not afraid of that
husband of yours you're mine and you're
going to stay mine I had listened
intently but could not recognize the
man's voice go now pleaded Gladys and
I'll come to your rooms this evening not
on your life I'm here now and I'm going
to stay let go of me you're hurting my
shoulder there was the sound of
scuffling I tried the door it was locked
I put my shoulder to it the lock snapped
Gladys gave a cry leaped away from the
man a man whom I had never seen before
the full lipped black-browed type big
and soft as I took in the scene the
tousled woman the flush faced man a
great wave of disgust almost overwhelmed
me well said the man sneeringly
what are you going to do about it
if you take her away now and treat her
right nothing and if I don't take her
away
I'll meet that situation when it comes
it has come he said with a laugh and
walked out I am tall slender delicate
looking but I knew I was a match for
that overfed brute I listened to the
clatter of his feet on the stairs then I
followed him the man was hastening
toward a streetcar I cranked Gladys's
car and followed it was easy to keep the
streetcar in sight and to keep an eye on
his sleek black head he left the car at
Hanson Street I without a glance toward
him kept on ahead I turned at the corner
in time to see him enter an office
building
I was not far behind him when he took
the elevator the man in the elevator
gave me the number of his office he was
telling a joke to his typist as I
entered but his laughter died when he
saw me you dirty thief
you'll never cheat another man out of
money his look of astonishment as I
shouted these words was amusing he tried
to give blow-for-blow but I meant what I
said when I shouted at him I've come
here to kill you
to choke the life out of an overfed
beast is not so hard to an infuriated
man in less than a quarter of an hour he
was dead the police for whom the typist
had called filled the room even before I
had straightened by disheveled clothing
I practically tried my own case and I
was skilful enough to make every word
apparently uttered in my own defense
sound black against me GLaDOS tried to
save me by telling the true story of the
affair but I made a picture of her as a
devoted self-sacrificing wife willing to
ruin even her spotless name to save her
husband I enjoyed seeing her cringe as I
did this so skillfully had she in the
big brute managed that there was not a
bit of evidence to substantiate her
story on the other hand that was the
typist story to help me and too it was
known I had speculated in the past and
that I had lost some money I made the
most of everything against me and it was
enough I was sentenced to hang on the
ninth day of June at sunrise GLaDOS came
to the jail to see me while the trial
was going on but I managed to act just
as if my story were the true one and
hers the false and though she pleaded
with me to let the truth come out I
would not admit that the truth had not
come out the sentence was a terrible
shock to her her mother carried her from
the courtroom in a faint before she
recovered I was in prison
I shall welcome the hour of sunrise as I
have never welcomed any moment of my
life not until then will the fear of a
reprieve leave me GLaDOS is moving
heaven and earth to locate the governor
god grant that she does not succeed it
is 4:45 I have spent much time at the
window gazing out into the darkness what
comes after death that is the question I
suppose that all men ask at the end of
life I have never done so it is a futile
question one which none of us can answer
but I believe there will be surcease
from the nausea that comes to those who
have known disillusion and
disappointment
ten minutes of five now surely I am safe
from even a chance of a reprieve
footsteps in the corridor is it my
escort to the gallows or what I fear
most on earth a statement by the warden
of Larsen penitentiary if trailer had
spent the brief period always allotted
to a criminal for a few last words his
reprieve would have reached us in time
to stay the execution but he walked
calmly unfalteringly up to the gallows
and helped us with steady hands adjust
the cap and ropes and he was dead two
minutes before the governor's message
reached us Blake had been in very low
water for months almost underwater part
of the time due to circumstances he was
fond of saying were no fault of his own
and as he sat writing in his room on
third floor back of a New York
boardinghouse part of his mind was
busily occupied in wondering when his
luck was going to turn again
it was his room only in the sense that
he paid the rent to friends one a little
Frenchman and the other a big Dane
shared it with him both hoping
eventually to contribute something
towards expenses but so far not having
accomplished this result they had two
beds only the third being a mattress
they slept upon in turns a week at a
time a good deal of their irregular
feeding consisted of oatmeal potatoes
and sometimes eggs all of which they
cooked on a strange utensil they had
contrived to fix into the gas jet
occasionally when dinner failed them
altogether they swallowed little raw
rice and drank hot water from the
bathroom on the top of it and then made
a wild race for bed so as to get to
sleep while the sensation of false
repletion was still there for sleep and
hunger are slight acquaintances as they
well knew fortunately all new york
houses are supplied with hot air and
they only had to open a grating in the
wall to get a plentiful if not a
wholesome amount of heat
the loneliness in a big city is a real
punishment as they had severally learnt
to their cost their experiences three in
a small room for several months had
revealed to them horrors of quite
another kind and their nerves had
suffered according to the temperament of
each but on this particular evening as
Blake sat scribbling by the only window
that was not cracked the Dane and the
Frenchman his companions in adversity
were in wonderful luck they had both
been asked out to a restaurant to dine
with a friend who also held out to one
of them a chance of work they would not
be back till late and when they did come
they were pretty sure to bring in
supplies of one kind or another for the
Frenchman could never resist the offer
of a glass of absinthe and this meant
that he would be able to help himself
plentifully from the free lunch counters
with which all New York bars are
furnished and to which any purchaser of
a drink is entitled to help himself and
devour on the spot or carry away
casually in his hand for consumption
elsewhere thousands of unfortunate men
get their sole subsistence in this way
in New York and experience soon teaches
where for the price of a single drink a
man can take away almost a meal of cheap
potatoes sausage bits of bread and even
eggs the Frenchman and the Dane knew
their way about and Blake looked forward
to a supper more or less substantial
before pulling his mattress out of the
cupboard and turning in upon the floor
for the night meanwhile he can enjoy a
quiet and lonely evening with a room all
to himself
in the daytime he was a reporter on an
evening newspaper of sensational and
lying habits his work was chiefly in the
police courts and in his spare hours at
night when not too tired or too empty he
wrote sketches and stories for the
magazines that very rarely saw the light
of day on their printed and paid for
sentences on this particular occasion he
was deep in a most involved tale of a
psychological character and had just
worked his way into a sentence or set of
sentences that completely baffled and
muddled him he was fairly out of his
depth and his brain was too poorly
supplied with blood to invent a way out
again the story would have been
interesting had he written it simply
keeping the facts and feelings and not
diving into difficult analysis of motive
and character which was quite beyond him
for it was largely autobiographical and
was meant to describe the adventures of
a young Englishman who had come to grief
in the usual manner on a Canadian farm
had then subsequently become barkeeper
sub editor on a Methodist magazine a
teacher of French and German two clerks
at twenty-five cents per hour a model
for artists a super on the stage and
finally a wanderer to the goldfields
Blake scratched his head and dipped the
pen in the ink pot stared out through
the blind 'less windows and sighed
deeply his thoughts kept wandering to
food beef steak and steaming vegetables
the smell of cooking that came from a
lower floor through the broken windows
was a constant torment to him he pulled
himself together and again attacked the
problem for with some people he wrote
the imagination is so vivid as to be
almost an extension of consciousness but
here he stuck absolutely he was not
quite sure what he meant by the words
and how to finish the sentence puzzled
him into blanket action it was a
difficult point to decide for it seemed
to come inappropriately at this point in
this story and he did not know whether
to leave it as it stood change it round
a bit or take it out altogether
it might just spoil its chances of being
accepted editors were such clever men
but to rewrite the sentence was a grind
and he was so tired and sleepy after all
what did it matter people who were
clever would force a meaning into it
people who were not clever would pretend
he knew of no other classes of readers
you would let it stay and go on with the
action at the story he put his head in
his hands and began to think hard his
mind soon passed from thought to reverie
he fell to wondering when his friends
would find work and relieve him of the
burden he acknowledged it as such of
keeping them and of letting another man
wear his best clothes on alternate
Sundays he wondered when his luck would
turn there were one or two influential
people in New York whom he could go and
see if he had a dress suit and the other
conventional uniforms his thoughts ran
on far ahead and at the same time by a
sort of double process far behind as
well his home in the old country rose up
before him he saw the lawn and the
Cedars in sunshine he looked through the
familiar windows and saw the clean swept
rooms his story began to suffer the
psychological masterpiece would not make
much progress unless he pulled up and
dragged his thoughts back to the
treadmill but he no longer cared once he
had got as far as that cedar with the
sunshine on it he never could get back
again for all he cared the Troublesome
sentence might run away and get into
someone else's pages or be snuffed out
altogether
there came a gentle knock at the door
and Blake started the knock was repeated
louder who in the world could it be at
this late hour of the night on the floor
above he remembered there lived in other
englishman a foolish second-rate
creature who sometimes came in and made
himself objectionable with endless and
silly chatter but he was an Englishman
for all that and Blake always tried to
treat him with politeness realizing that
he was lonely in a strange land
but tonight of all people in the world
he did not want to be bored with Perry's
cackle as he called it and to come in he
gave an answer to the second knock had
no very cordial sound of welcome in it
however the door opened in response and
the man came in Blake did not turn round
at once and the other advanced to the
center of the room but without speaking
then Blake knew it was not his enemy
parry and turned round he saw a man of
about forty standing in the middle of
the carpet but standing sideways so that
he did not present a full face he wore
an overcoat buttoned up to the neck and
on the felt hat which he held in front
of him
fresh raindrops glistened in his other
hand he carried a small black bag Blake
gave him a good look and came to the
conclusion that he might be a secretary
or a chief clerk or a confidential man
of sorts he was a shabby respectable
looking person this was the sum total of
the first impression gains a moment his
eyes took in that it was not peri the
second impression was less pleasant and
reported at once that something was
wrong though otherwise young and
inexperienced
Blake thanks or curses to the police
court training knew more about common
criminal blackguard ISM than most men of
50 and he recognized that there was
somewhere a suggestion of this
undesirable world about the man but
there was more than this there was
something singular about him something
far out of the common though for the
life of him Blake could not say where in
it lay the fellow was out of the
ordinary and in some very undesirable
manner all this that takes so long to
describe Blake saw with the first and
second glance the man at once began to
speak in a quiet and respectable voice
are you mr. Blake he asked I am
mr. Arthur Blake yes mr. Arthur Herbert
Blake persisted the other with emphasis
on the middle name that is my full name
Blake answered simply adding as he
remembered his manners but won't you sit
down first please
the man advanced with a curious sideways
motion like a crab and took a seat on
the edge of the sofa he put his hat on
the floor at his feet but still kept the
bag in his hand I come to you from a
well-wisher he went on at oily tones
without lifting his eyes Blake in his
mind ran quickly over all the people he
knew in New York who might possibly have
sent such a man while waiting for him to
supply the name but the man had come to
a full stop and was waiting - a
well-wisher of mine repeated Blake not
knowing quite what else to say just so
replied the other still with his eyes on
the floor a well-wisher of yours a man
or he felt himself blushing or a woman
that said the man shortly I cannot tell
you you can't tell me exclaimed the
other wondering what was coming next and
who in the world this mysterious
well-wisher could be who sent so
discreet and mysterious a messenger I
cannot tell you the name replied the man
firmly those are my instructions but I
bring you something from this person and
I am to give it to you to take a receipt
for it and then to go away without
answering any questions
Blake stared very hard the man however
never raised his eyes above the level of
the second China knob on the chest of
drawers opposite the giving of a receipt
sounded like money could it be that some
of his influential friends had heard of
his plight there were possibilities that
made his heart beat at length however he
found his tongue for this strange
creature was determined apparently to
say nothing more until he had heard from
him then what have you got for me please
he asked bluntly by way of answer the
man proceeded to open the bag
he took out a parcel wrapped loosely in
brown paper and about the size of a
large book it was tied with string and
the man seemed unnecessarily long
untying the knot when at last the string
was off and the paper unfolded there
appeared a series of smaller packages
inside the man took them out very
carefully almost as if they had been
alive Blake thought and set them in a
row upon his knees
they were dollar bills
lake all in a flutter craned his neck
forward a little to try and make out
their denomination he read plainly the
figures 100 there are $10,000 here said
the man quietly the other could not
suppress a little cry and therefore you
Blake simply gasped $10,000 he repeated
a queer feeling growing up in his throat
10,000 are you sure
I mean you mean they're for me he's
stammered he felt quite silly with
excitement and grew more so with every
minute as the man maintained a perfect
silence was it not a dream wouldn't the
man put them back in the bag presently
and say it was a mistake that they were
meant for somebody else he could not
believe his eyes or his ears yet in a
sense it was possible he had read of
such things in books and even come
across them in his experience of the
courts the erratic and generous
philanthropist who's determined to do
his good deed and to get no thanks or
acknowledgment for it still it seemed
almost incredible his troubles began to
melt away like bubbles in the Sun he
thought of the other fellows when they
came in and what he would have to tell
them he thought of the German landlady
in the arrears of rent of regular food
and clean linen and books and music of
the chance of getting into some
respectable business of well of as many
things as it's possible to think of when
excitement and surprise fling wide open
the gates of the imagination
the man meanwhile began quietly to count
over the packages aloud from one to ten
and then to count the bills in each
separate packet also from one to ten yes
there were ten little heaps each
containing ten bills of $100
denomination that made $10,000 Blake had
never seen so much money in a single
lump in his life before and for many
months of privation and discomfort he
had not known the feel of a $20 note
much less of $100 one he heard them
crackle under the man's fingers and it
was like crisp laughter in his ears the
bills were evidently new and unused
but side-by-side with the excitement
caused by the shock of such an event
Blake's caution acquired by a year of
vivid New York experience was meanwhile
beginning to assert itself it all seemed
just a little too much out of the likely
order of things to be quite right
the police courts had taught him the
amazing ingenuity of the criminal mind
as well as something of the plots and
devices by which the unwary are beguiled
into the dark places where blackmail may
be levied with impunity New York as a
matter of fact just at that time was
literally undermined with the secret
ways at the blackmailers the green Goods
men and other police protected
abominations and the only weak point in
the supposition that this was part of
some such proceeding was the selection
of himself a poor newspaper reporter as
a victim it did seem absurd but then the
whole thing was so out of the ordinary
and the thought once having entered his
mind was not so easily got rid of Blake
resolved to be very cautious
the man meanwhile though he never
appeared to raise his eyes from the
carpet had been watching him closely all
the time if you'll give me a receipt
I'll leave the money at once he said
with just a vestige of impatience in his
tone as if you were anxious to bring the
matter to a conclusion as soon as
possible but you say it is quite
impossible for you to tell me the name
of my well-wisher or why she sends me
such a large sum of money in this
extraordinary way the money is sent to
you because you are in need of it
returned the other and it is a present
without conditions of any sort attached
you have to give me a receipt only to
satisfy the sender that it has reached
your hands the money will never be asked
of you again
Blake noticed two things from this
answer first that the man was not to be
caught into betraying the sex of the
well-wisher and secondly that he was in
some hurry to complete the transaction
for he was now giving reasons attractive
reasons why he should accept the money
and make out the receipt suddenly it
flashed across his mind that if he took
the money and gave the receipt before a
witness nothing very disastrous could
come of the affair it would protect him
against blackmail if this was after all
a plot of some sort with blackmail in it
whereas if the man were a madman or a
criminal who was getting rid of a
portion of his ill-gotten gains to
divert suspicion or if any other
improbable explanation turned out to be
the true one there was no great harm
done and he could hold the money till it
was claimed or advertised for in the
newspapers his mind rapidly ran over
these possibilities though of course
under the stress of excitement he was
unable to weigh any of them properly
then he turned to a strange visitor
again and said quietly I will take the
money although I must say it seems to me
a very unusual transaction and I will
give you for it such a receipt as I
think proper under the circumstances a
proper receipt is all I want was the
answer I mean by that a receipt before a
proper witness perfectly satisfactory
interrupted the man his eyes still on
the carpet only it must be dated and
headed with your address here in the
correct way Blake could see no possible
objection to this and he had once
proceeded to obtain his witness the
person he had in his mind was a Mr
Barclay who occupied the room above his
own an old gentleman who had retired
from business and who the landlady
always said was a miser and kept large
sums secret and in his room he was at
any rate a perfectly respectable man and
would make an admirable witness to a
transaction of this sort Blake made an
apology and rose to fetch him crossing
the room in front of the sofa where the
man sat in order to reach the door as he
did so he saw for the first time the
other side of the visitors face the side
that had been always so carefully turned
away from him
there was a broad smear of blood down
the skin from the ear to the neck it
glistened in the Gaslight Blake never
knew how he managed to smother the cry
that sprang to his lips but smother it
he did in a second he was at the door
his knees trembling his mind and a
sudden and dreadful turmoil his main
object so far as he could recollect
afterwards was to escape from the room
as if he had noticed nothing so as not
to arouse the other suspicions the man's
eyes were always on the carpet and
probably Blake hoped he had not noticed
the consternation that must have been
written plainly on his face at any rate
he had uttered no cry in another second
he would have been in the passage when
suddenly he met a pair of wicked staring
eyes fixed intently and with a cunning
smile upon his own it was the others
face in the mirror calmly watching his
every movement instantly all his powers
of reflection flew to the winds and he
thought only upon the desirability of
getting help at once he tore upstairs
his heart in his mouth
Barclay must come to his aid this matter
was serious
perhaps horribly serious taking the
money or giving a receipt or having
anything at all to do with it became an
impossibility here was crime he felt
certain of it in three bounds he reached
the next landing and began to hammer at
the old misers door as if his very life
depended on it for a long time he could
get no answer his fist seemed to make no
noise he might have been knocking on
cotton wool and the thought dashed
through his brain that it was all just
like the terror of a nightmare
barclay evidently was still out or else
sound asleep but the other simply could
not wait a minute longer in suspense he
turned the handle and walked into the
room at first he saw nothing for the
darkness and made sure the owner of the
room was out but the moment the light
from the passage began a little to
disperse the gloom he saw the old man to
his immense relief lying asleep on the
bed
Blake opened the door to its widest to
get more light and then walked quickly
up to the bed he now saw the figure more
plainly and noted that it was dressed
and lay only upon the outside of the bed
it struck him too that he was sleeping
in a very odd almost an unnatural
position something clutched at his heart
as he looked closer he stumbled over a
chair and found the matches calling upon
Barclay the whole time to wake up and
come downstairs with him he blundered
across the floor a dreadful thought in
his mind and lit the gas over the table
it seemed strange that there was no
movement or replies his shouting but it
no longer seemed strange when at length
he turned in the full glare of the gas
and saw the old man lying huddled up
into a ghastly heap on the bed his
throat cut across from ear to ear and
all over the carpet laid new dollar
bills crisp and clean like those he had
left downstairs and strewn about in
little heaps for a moment Blake stood
Stockstill bereft of all power of
movement the next his courage returned
and he fled from the room and -
downstairs taking five steps at a time
he reached the bottom and tore along the
passage to his room determined at any
rate to seize the man and prevent his
escape till help came
but when he got to the end of the little
landing he found that his door had been
closed he seized the handle fumbling
with it in his violence
it felt slippery and kept turning under
his fingers without opening the door and
fully half a minute passed before it
yielded and let him in headlong at the
first glance he saw the room was empty
and the man gone scattered upon the
carpet lay a number of the bills and
beside them half hidden under the sofa
where the man had sat he saw a pair of
gloves thick leather gloves and a
butcher's knife even from the distance
where he stood the bloodstains on both
were easily visible dazed and confused
by the terrible discoveries the last few
minutes Blake stood in the middle of the
room overwhelmed and unable to think or
move unconsciously he must have passed
his hand over his forehead in the
natural gesture perplexity for he
noticed that the skin felt wet and
sticky his hand was covered with blood
and when he rushed in terror to the
looking glass he saw that there was a
broad red smear across his face and
forehead then he remembered the slippery
handle of the door and knew that it had
been carefully moistened in an instant
the whole plot became clear as daylight
and he was so spellbound with horror
that a sort of numbness came over him
and he came very near to fainting he was
in a condition of utter helplessness and
had anyone come into the room at that
minute and called him by name he would
simply have dropped to the floor in a
heap if the police were to come in now
the thought crashed through his brain
like thunder and at the same moment
almost before he had time to appreciate
a quarter of its significance there came
a loud knocking at the front door below
the bell rang with a dreadful clamor
men's voices were heard talking
excitedly and presently heavy steps
began to come up the stairs in the
direction of his room it was the police
and all Blake could do was laugh
foolishly to himself and wait till they
were upon him he could not move or speak
he stood face to face with the evidence
of his horrid crime his hands and face
smeared with the blood of his victim and
there he was standing when the police
burst opened the door and came noisily
into the room here it is cried a voice
he knew third floor back and the fellow
caught red-handed it was the man with
the bag leading in the two policemen
hardly knowing what he was doing in the
fearful stress of conflicting emotions
he made a step forward but before he had
time to make a second one he felt the
heavy hand of the law descend upon both
shoulders at once as the two policemen
moved up to seize him at the same moment
a voice of thunder cried in his ear wake
up man
wake up here's the supper and good news
too Blake turned with a start in his
chair and saw the Dane very red in the
face standing beside him a hand on each
shoulder and a little further back he
saw the Frenchman leering happily at him
over the end of the bed a bottle of beer
in one hand and a paper package in the
other he rubbed his eyes glancing from
one to the other and then got up
sleepily to fix the wire arrangement on
the gas jet to boil water for cooking
the eggs which the Frenchman was in
momentary danger of letting drop upon
the floor
[Music]
I've always noticed a prevalent want of
courage even among persons of superior
intelligence in culture as to imparting
their own psychological experiences when
those have been of a strange sort almost
all men are afraid that what they could
relate and such wise would find no
parallel response in a listeners
internal life and might be suspected or
laughed at a truthful traveler who
should have seen some extraordinary
creature in the likeness of a sea
serpent would have no fear of mentioning
it but the same traveler having had some
singular presentiment impulse vagary of
thought so-called vision dream or other
remarkable mental impression would
hesitate considerably before he would
own to it to this reticence I attribute
much of the obscurity in which such
subjects are involved we do not
habitually communicate our experiences
of these subjective things as we do our
experiences of objective creation the
consequence is that the general stock of
experience in this regard appears
exceptional and really is so in respect
to being miserably imperfect in what I'm
going to relate I have no intention of
setting up opposing or supporting any
theory whatever I know the history of
the bookseller Berlin I've studied the
case of the wife of a late astronomer
royal as related by Sir David Brewster
and I have followed the my nudist
details of a much more remarkable case
of spectral illusion occurring within my
private circle of friends it may be
necessary to state as to this last that
the sufferer a lady was in no degree
however distant related to me a mistaken
assumption on that head might suggest an
explanation of a part of my own case but
only a part which would be wholly
without foundation
it cannot be referred to my inheritance
of any developed peculiarities nor had I
ever before any at all similar
experience nor have I ever had any at
all similar experience since
it does not signify how many years ago
or how few a certain murder was
committed in England which attracted
great attention we hear more than enough
of murderers as they rise in succession
to their atrocious eminence and I would
bury the memory of this particular brute
if I could as his body was buried in
Newgate Jail
I purposely abstained from giving any
direct clue to the criminals
individuality when the murder was first
discovered no suspicion fell or I ought
rather to say for I cannot be too
precise in my facts it was nowhere
publicly hinted that any suspicion fell
on the man who was afterwards brought to
trial as no reference was at that time
made to him in the newspapers it is
obviously impossible that any
description of him can at that time have
been given in the newspapers it is
essential that this fact be remembered
unfolding at breakfast my morning paper
containing the account of that first
discovery I found it to be deeply
interesting and I read it with close
attention I read it twice if not three
times the discovery had been made in a
bedroom and when I laid down the paper I
was aware of a flash rush flow I don't
know what to call it no word I can find
as satisfactorily descriptive in which I
seemed to see that bedroom passing
through my room like a picture and
possibly painted on a running river
though almost instantaneous in its
passing it was perfectly clear so clear
that I distinctly and with a sense of
relief observe the absence of the dead
body from the bed it was in no romantic
place that I had this curious sensation
but in chambers and Piccadilly very near
to the corner of st. James Street it was
entirely new to me I was in my easy
chair at the moment and the sensation
was accompanied with a peculiar shiver
which started the chair from its
position but it is to be noted that the
chair ran easily on Castor's I went to
one of the windows there are two in the
room and the room is on the second floor
to refresh my eyes with the moving
objects down in Piccadilly it was a
bright autumn morning and the street was
sparkling and cheerful the wind was high
as I looked out it brought down from the
park a quantity of fallen leaves which a
gust took in whirled into a spiral
pillar as the pillar fell in the leaves
dispersed I saw two men on the opposite
side of the
going from west to east they were one
behind the other the foremost man often
looked back over his shoulder
the second man followed him at a
distance of some 30 paces with his right
hand menacingly raised first the
singularity and steadiness of this
threatening gesture in so public a
thoroughfare attracted my attention and
next the more remarkable circumstance
that nobody heeded it
both men threaded their way among the
other passengers with a smoothness
hardly consistent even with the action
of walking on a pavement and no single
creature that I could see gave them
place touch them or looked after them in
passing before my windows they both
stared up at me I saw their two faces
very distinctly and I knew that I could
recognize them anywhere not that I had
consciously noticed anything very
remarkable in either face except that
the man who went first had an unusually
Laur in appearance and that the face of
the man who followed him was the color
of impure wax I am a bachelor and my
valet and his wife constitute my whole
establishment my occupation is in a
certain branch bank and I wish that my
duties as head of a department were as
light as they are popularly supposed to
be they kept me in town that autumn when
I stood in need of a change
I was not ill but I was not well my
reader is to make the most that can be
reasonably made of my feeling jaded
having a depressing sense upon me of a
monotonous life and being slightly
dyspeptic I am assured by myrin own
doctor that my real state of health at
that time justifies no stronger
description and I quote his own from his
written answer to my request for it
as the circumstances of the murder
gradually unraveling took stronger and
stronger possession of the public mind I
kept them away from mine by knowing as
little about them as was possible in the
midst of the universal excitement but I
knew that a verdict of willful murder
had been found against the suspected
murderer and that he had been committed
to Newgate for trial I also knew that
his trial had been postponed over one
sessions of the Central Criminal Court
on the ground of general prejudice and
want of time for the preparation of the
defense I may further have known but I
believe I did not when or about when the
sessions to which his trial stood
postponed would come on my sitting-room
bedroom and dressing room are all on one
floor with the last there is no
communication but through the bedroom
true there is a door in it once
communicating with the staircase but a
part of the fitting of my bath has been
and had then been for some years fixed
across it at the same period and as a
part of the same arrangement the door
had been nailed up and canvassed over I
was standing in my bedroom late one
night giving some directions to my
servant before he went to bed my face
was towards the only available door of
communication with the dressing room and
it was closed My servants back was
towards that door while I was speaking
to him I saw it open and a man looking
who very earnestly and mysteriously
beckoned to me that man was the man who
had gone second of the two along
Piccadilly and whose face was of the
color of impure wax the figure having
beckoned drew back and closed the door
with no longer pause than was made by my
crossing the bedroom
I opened the dressing-room door and
looked in I had a lighted candle already
in my hand I felt no inward expectation
of seeing the figure in the dressing
room and I did not see it there
conscious that my servant stood amazed I
turned round to him and said Derrick
could you believe that in my cool senses
I fancied I saw as I there laid my hand
upon his breast with a sudden start he
trembled violently and said Oh Lord yes
sir
a dead man beckoning now I do not
believe that this John Derrick my trusty
and attached servant for more than
twenty years had any impression whatever
of having seen any such figure until I
touched him the change in him was so
startling when I touched him that I
fully believed he derived his impression
in some occult manner for me at that
instant I bade John Derrick bring me
some brandy and I gave him a dram and
was glad to take one myself of what had
preceded that nights phenomenon I told
him not a single word reflecting on it I
was absolutely certain that I had never
seen that face before except on the one
occasion in Piccadilly comparing its
expression when beckoning at the door
with its expression when it had stared
up at me as I stood at my window I came
to the conclusion that on the first
occasion it had sought to fasten itself
upon my memory and that on the second
occasion it had made sure being
immediately remembered I was not very
comfortable that night though I felt a
certainty difficult to explain that the
figure would not return at daylight I
fell into a heavy sleep from which I was
awakened by John Derrick's coming to my
bedside with a paper in his hand this
paper it appeared had been the subject
of an altercation at the door between
its bearer and my servant it was a
summons to me to serve upon a jury at
the forthcoming sessions of the Central
Criminal Court at the Old Bailey I had
never before been summoned on such a
jury as John Derrick well knew he
believed
I'm not certain at this hour whether
with reason or otherwise that that class
of jurors were customarily chosen on a
lower qualification than mine and he had
at first refused to accept the summons
the man who served it had taken the
matter very coolly he had said that my
attendance or not attendance was nothing
to him there the summons was and I
should deal with it at my own peril and
not at his for a day or two I was
undecided whether to respond to this
call or take no notice of
I was not conscious of the slightest
mysterious bias influence or attraction
one way or other of that I am is
strictly sure as of every other
statement that I make here ultimately I
decided as a break in the monotony of my
life that I would go the appointed
morning was a raw morning in the month
of November there was a dense brown fog
in Piccadilly and it became positively
black and in the last degree oppressive
east of Temple Bar I found the passages
and staircases of the courthouse flaring
Li lighted with gas and the Court itself
similarly illuminated I think that until
I was conducted by officers into the old
court and saw its crowded state I did
not know that the murderer was to be
tried that day I think that until I was
so helped into the old court with
considerable difficulty I did not know
into which of the two courts sitting my
summons would take me but this must not
be received as a positive assertion for
I'm not completely satisfied in my mind
on either point I took my seat in the
place appropriated to jurors and waiting
and I looked about the court as well as
I could through the cloud of fog and
breath that was heavy in it I noticed
the black vapor hanging like a murky
curtain outside the great windows and I
noticed the stifled sound of wheels on
the straw or tan that was littered in
the street also the hum of the people
gathered there which a shrill whistle or
a louder song or hail than the rest
occasionally pierced soon afterwards the
judges to a number entered and took
their seats the buzz and the court was
awfully hushed the direction was given
to put the murderer to the bar he
appeared there and in that same instant
I recognized in him the first of the two
men who had gone down Piccadilly if my
name had been called then I doubt I
could have answered to it audibly but it
was called about sixth or eighth in the
panel and I was by that time able to say
here now observe as I stepped into the
box the prisoner who had been looking on
attentively
but with no sign of concern became
violently agitated and beckoned to his
attorney
the prisoners wish to challenge me was
so manifest that had occasioned a pause
during which the attorney with his hand
upon the dock whispered with his client
and shook his head
I afterwards had it from that gentleman
that the prisoners first affrighted
words to him were at All Hazards
challenge that man but that as he would
give no reason for it and admitted that
he had not even known my name until he
heard it called and I appeared it was
not done both on the ground already
explained that I wish to avoid reviving
the unwholesome memory of that murderer
and also because a detailed account of
his long trial is by no means
indispensable to my narrative
I shall confine myself closely to such
incidents in the ten days and nights
during which we the jury were kept
together as directly bear on my own
curious personal experience it is in
that and not in the murderer that I seek
to interest my reader it is to that and
not to a page of the new gate calendar
that I beg attention I was chosen
Foreman of the jury on the second
morning of the trial after evidence had
been taken for two hours
I heard the church clock strike
happening to cast my eyes over my
brother jurymen I found an inexplicable
difficulty in counting them I counted
them several times yet always with the
same difficulty in short I made them one
too many I touched the brother jury men
whose place was next to me and I
whispered to him oblige me by counting
us he looked surprised by the request
but turned his head and counted why says
he suddenly we're third but no that's
not possible
no were twelve
according to my counting that day we
were always right in detail but in the
gross we were always one too many
there was no appearance no figure to
account for it but I had now an inward
foreshadowing of the figure that was
surely coming the jury were housed at
the London tavern we all slept in one
large room on separate tables and we
were constantly in the charge and under
the eye of the officers weren't to hold
us in safekeeping I see no reason for
suppressing the real name of that
officer he was intelligent highly polite
and obliging and I was glad to hear much
respected in the city he had an
agreeable presence good eyes and
viewable black whiskers and a fine
sonorous voice his name was mr. Harker
when we turned into our twelve beds at
night mr. Harker's bed was drawn across
the door on the night of the second day
not being disposed to lie down and
seeing mr. Harker sitting on his bed I
went and sat beside him and offered him
a pinch of snuff
as mr. Harker's hand touched mine and
taking it from my box a peculiar shiver
crossed him and he said who is this
following mr. Harker XY's and looking
along the room I saw again the figure I
expected the second of the two men who
had gone down Piccadilly I rose and
advanced a few steps then stopped and
looked round at mr. Harker he was quite
unconcerned laughed and said in a
pleasant way I thought for a moment we
had a thirteenth jurymen without a bed
but I see it as the moonlight making no
revelation to mr. Harker but inviting
him to take a walk with me to the end of
the room I watched what the figure did
it stood for a few moments by the
bedside of each of my eleven brother
jurymen close to the pillow it always
went to the right-hand side of the bed
and always passed out crossing the foot
of the next bed it seemed from the
action of the head merely to look down
pensively at each recumbent figure it
took no notice of me or of my bed which
was that nearest to mr. Harker's it
seemed to go out where the moonlight
came in through a high window as by an
aerial flight of stairs
next morning at breakfast it appeared
that everybody present had dreamed at
the murdered man last night except
myself and mr. Harker I now felt as
convinced that the second man who had
gone down Piccadilly was the murdered
man so to speak as if it had been born
into my comprehension by his immediate
testimony but even this took place and
in a manner for which I was not at all
prepared on the fifth day of the trial
when the case for the prosecution was
drawing to a close a miniature of the
murdered man missing from his bedroom
upon the discovery of the deed and
afterwards found in a hiding place where
the murderer had been seen digging was
put into evidence
having been identified by the witness
under examination it was handed up to
the bench and thence handed down to be
inspected by the jury as an officer and
a black gown was making his way with it
across to me the figure of the second
man who had gone down Piccadilly
impetuous Lee started from the crowd
caught the miniature from the officer
and gave it to me with his own hands at
the same time saying in a low and hollow
tone before I saw the miniature which
was in a locket I was younger then and
my face was not then drained of blood it
also came between me and the brother
jurymen to whom I would have given the
miniature and between him and the
brother jurymen to whom he would have
given it and so passed it on through the
whole of our number and back into my
possession not one of them however
detected this at table and generally
when we were shut up together and mr.
Harker's custody we had from the first
naturally discussed the day's
proceedings a good deal on that fifth
day the case for the prosecution being
closed and we having that side of the
question in a completed shape before us
our discussion was more animated and
serious among our number was a vest
rumen the densest idiot I've ever seen
at large who met the plainest evidence
with the most preposterous objections
and he was cited with by too flabby
parochial parasites all the three
impaled from a district so delivered
over to fever that they ought to have
been upon their own trial for five
hundred murders when these mischievous
Blockheads were at their loudest which
was towards midnight while some of us
were already preparing for bed I again
saw the murdered man he stood grimly
behind them beckoning to me
on my going towards them and striking
into the conversation
he immediately retired this was the
beginning of a separate series of
appearances confined to that long room
in which we were confined whenever a
knot of my brother jurymen laid their
heads together I saw the head of the
murdered man among theirs whenever their
comparison of notes was going against
him he would solemnly and irresistible
beckon to me it will be borne in mind
that down to the production of the
miniature on the fifth day of the trial
I had never seen the appearance in court
three changes occurred now that we
entered on the case for the defense two
of them I will mention together first
the figure was now in court continually
and it never there addressed itself to
me but always to the person who was
speaking at the time for instance the
throat of the murdered man had been cut
straight across in the opening speech
for the defense it was suggested that
the deceased might have cut his own
throat at that very moment the figure
with its throat in the dreadful
condition referred to this it had
concealed before stood at the speaker's
elbow motioning across and across its
windpipe now with the right hand now
with the left vigorously suggesting to
the speaker himself the impossibility of
such a wound having been self-inflicted
by either hand for another instance a
witness to character a woman deposed to
the prisoners being the most amiable of
mankind the figure at that instant stood
on the floor before her looking her full
in the face and pointing out the
prisoners evil countenance with an
extended arm and an outstretched finger
the third change now to be added
impressed me strongly as the most market
and striking of all I do not fear eyes
upon it I accurately state it and there
leave it all though the appearance was
not itself perceived by those who met
addressed its coming close to such
persons was invariably attended by some
trepidation or disturbance on their part
it seemed to me as if it were prevented
by laws to which I was not amenable from
fully revealing itself to others and yet
as if it could invisibly dumbly and
darkly overshadow their mind
when the leading counsel for the defense
suggested that hypothesis of suicide and
the figure stood at the Lerner
gentleman's elbow frightfully sawing at
its severed throat it is undeniable that
the counsel faltered in his speech lost
for a few seconds the threat of his
ingenious discourse wiped his forehead
with his handkerchief and turned
extremely pale when the witness to
character was confronted by the
appearance her eyes most certainly did
followed the direction of its pointed
finger and rest in great hesitation and
trouble upon the prisoners face two
additional illustrations will suffice on
the eighth day of the trial after the
pause which was every day made early in
the afternoon for a few minutes rest and
refreshment I came back into court with
the rest of the jury some little time
before the return of the judges standing
up in the box and looking about me
I thought the figure was not there until
chancing to raise my eyes to the gallery
I saw it bending forward and leaning
over a very decent woman as if to assure
itself whether the judges had resumed
their seats or not immediately
afterwards that woman screamed fainted
and was carried out so with the
venerable sagacious and patient judge
who conducted the trial when the case
was over and he settled himself in his
papers to sum up the murdered man
entering by the judges door advanced to
his Lordships desk and looked eagerly
over his shoulder at the pages of his
notes which he was turning a change came
over his Lordships face his hand stopped
the peculiar shiver that I knew so well
passed over him he faltered
excuse me gentlemen for a few moments
I'm someone oppressed by the vitiated
Adair and did not recover until he had
drunk a glass of water through all the
monotony of six of those interminable
ten days the same judges and others on
the bench the same murderer and the doc
the same lawyers at the table the same
tones of question and answer rising to
the roof of the court the same
scratching of the judges pen the same
rushers going in and out the same lights
kindled at the same hour when there had
been any natural light of day the same
foggy curtain outside the great windows
when it was foggy the same rain
pattering and dripping when it was rainy
the same footmarks of turnkeys and
prisoner day off
they on the same sawdust the same keys
locking and unlocking the same heavy
doors through all the wearisome monotony
which made me feel as if I had been
Foreman of the jury for a vast cried of
time and Piccadilly had flourished Co
evilly with Babylon the murdered man
never lost one trace of his distinctness
in my eyes nor was he at any moment less
distinct than anybody else I must not
omit as a matter of fact that I never
once saw the appearance which I call by
the name of the murdered man look at the
murderer again and again I wondered why
does he not but he never did nor did he
look at me after the production of the
miniature until the last closing minutes
of the trial arrived we retired to
consider at seven minutes before 10:00
at night the idiotic vestry men and his
to parochial parasites gave us so much
trouble that we twice returned into
court to beg to have certain extracts
from the judges notes reread nine of us
had not the smallest doubt about those
passages neither I believe had anyone in
the court the dunderheaded triumvirate
having no idea but obstruction disputed
them for that very reason at length we
prevailed and finally the jury returned
into court at ten minutes past twelve
the murdered man at that time stood
directly opposite the jury box on the
other side of the court as I took my
place his eyes rested on me with great
attention he seemed satisfied and slowly
shook a great gray veil which he carried
on his arm for the first time over his
head and whole form as I gave in our
verdict guilty the veil collapsed all
was gone and his place was empty
the murderer being asked by the judge
according to usage whether he had
anything to say before sentence of death
should be passed upon him indistinctly
muttered something which was described
in the leading newspapers of the
following day as a few rambling
incoherent and half audible words in
which he was understood to complain that
he had not had a fair trial because the
foreman of the jury was prepossessed
against him
the remarkable declaration that he
really made was this my lord I knew I
was a doomed man when the foreman of my
jury came into the box
my lord I knew he would never let me off
because before I was taken he somehow
got to my bedside in the night woke me
and put a rope around my neck
you